>> Stephanie Stillo:
Well, welcome everyone.
We are so happy to see you here
at our Thursdays at Three talks.
So many familiar
faces, which is lovely.
So we are delighted to be able
to host Chet Van Duzer today
to talk about his new book
about Henricus Martellus
and the World Map at Yale,
multispectral imaging
sources and influence.
So this talk gives an account
of a project that's funded
by the NEH Endowment
for the Humanities
to make multispectral images of
the world map made by Martellus
in about 1491, which, of course,
is held at the Beinecke
Library at Yale.
And this talk will certainly
talk about the necessity
of these types of
images for scholarship.
As a scholar, Chet is
largely interested in medieval
and renascence maps, and he
is quite a notable presence
in the field.
He has an emphasis on
determining the sources
that cartographers use for text,
images and geographical
features on maps.
And he's given several really
wonderful talks about this
at the Library of Congress.
Several of them are
streaming on our website,
so please do check them out.
He has had several research
fellowships at the Library
of Congress at Princeton,
John Carter Brown,
the Huntington Clements Library.
He's also a board member
on the Lazarus Project
at the University
of Mississippi,
which provides low-cost access
to multispectral imaging
to institutions and
researchers around the world.
To say the least, Chet
is a formidable scholar.
And what I admire most about
his work is his ability
to add just this amazing
historical depth to topics
that are as wide ranging
as annotations in 15th
and 16th century thalamic
atlases to medieval images
of dragons and serpents
on the high seas.
He's really this
sort of amazing voice
in the history of cartography.
Now, at this point, he
has enough publications
that I'm worried
about the amount
of sleep he gets
on a regular basis.
But a few of his notable books
are Seeing the World Anew,
which he cowrote
with John in 2012
about the Martin
Waldseemuller 1507 world map
and the 1516 Carta Marina,
Sea Monsters on Medieval
and Renascence maps from
2014, Apocalyptic Cartography,
how could you not love that
title, absolutely fantastic,
in 2015, Canada Before
Federation,
which was a fabulous
book which analyzed
and contextualized maps
featured in a traveling exhibit
from 2017, exploring through the
early exploration and mapping
of Canada, so really lovely.
And now we have this
new book as well.
So again, a formidable
scholar in the field.
We are so happy to
have him here.
So please help me
to welcome Chet.
[ Applause ]
>> Chet Van Duzer: Well,
thank you all for coming.
It's a pleasure to be here.
This is a talk about this book,
which is just out from Springer
and is available for purchase
at the desk to the side there.
And it's a particular pleasure
to present this material here
because a map that
figures prominently
in this talk is Martin
Waldseemuller's world map
of 1507, one of the treasures
of the Library of Congress,
and the Library's
copy is the only one
that survives of this map.
This is the map that will be
the focus of this presentation.
It was made by Henricus
Martellus,
a German cartographer
working in Florence
in the second half
of the 15th century.
It surfaced in Bern,
Switzerland in the late 1950s.
There was a flurry
of interest in it,
a couple of unpublished studies
that confirmed its
importance and authenticity.
And then it was this sort
of great unstudied object
for about 60 years
because, as I'll show later,
most of the text on the map
had faded to illegibility.
But the map was sold, purchased
and anonymously donated to Yale,
and it's been in the
Beinecke Library ever since.
I'll begin by looking
at the development
of Henricus Martellus'
world maps over time,
and he made manuscripts
of Ptolemy's Geography.
I'll begin with Ptolemy's
Geography.
Here we have a folio of a
manuscript of the geography.
The geography consists of
instructions for making maps,
a large database of place names
with their latitudes
and longitudes.
And we see here there are
about 8,000 place names
with their latitudes
and longitudes.
And then in many of the
surviving manuscripts
in many printed editions
of the work,
there are the Ptolemy
maps themselves.
This is Ptolemy's
so-called second projection
for making a world map, so
we'll examine this briefly.
So here's the equator,
tropic of Capricorn,
so 23 1/2 degrees south
is the southern limit
of Ptolemy's world map.
Tropic of Cancer about
23 1/2 degrees north.
And the Arctic Circle at
about 66 1/2 degrees north,
which is the northern limit
of Ptolemy's world map.
The map covers 180 degrees of
longitude, which is to say half
of the Earth's circumference.
And Ptolemy was very
conscious of the fact
that the map did not include all
of the Earth's circumference.
So if we fix this image,
this diagram, in our mind,
I will now switch to a world
map made using this diagram,
which we have here.
This is a world map in
one of the manuscripts
of Ptolemy's Geography
made by Henricus Martellus.
So this is a world map
by Henricus Martellus.
We don't see a Ptolemaic
world map every day,
so I'll run through a
few details to orient us.
So here we have Europe,
the Mediterranean, Africa,
the Arabian Peninsula, Asia,
and it's important to point
out that Ptolemy does not know
the eastern coast of Asia.
We did not have water to the
east of the Asian mainland.
The Indian Ocean, the
Island of Taprobana,
which is generally
identified with Sri Lanka.
We move now to another world
map made by Henricus Martellus.
This is in a manuscript
of his island book,
so a book about the world's
islands illustrated with maps.
A few of the manuscripts,
including this one
in the British Library,
include a world map.
If we compare this with the
Ptolemaic world map made
by Martellus, so the Ptolemaic
map covers 180 degrees
of longitude.
The map in the island book does
not have a scale of longitude,
but estimating, it covers
about 240 degrees of longitude.
I've indicated some
corresponding points on the map.
So what the map in the island
book includes that is not
in the Ptolemaic
map is Eastern Asia.
So and specifically we can see
that now Asia is depicted all
the way to the Eastern Coast.
If we compare this map
with the map at Yale,
it does have a scale
of longitude and runs
to 280 degrees of longitude
and again indicating a
corresponding point there,
we can see that what Martellus
has added on this map is more
of the Eastern Ocean,
all the way to Japan.
And if we think about the
fact that we're talking
about the cartographic career
of one person, it's remarkable
that during that career,
the amount of the Earth's
circumference depicted went
from 180 degrees to 280 degrees.
It's quite a remarkable advance.
And the new material
on this map,
that is the post-Ptolemaic
material, comes essentially
from Marco Polo, and it's
actually quite easy to indicate
with the line, the division
between those sources
of information.
So the importance of
the Yale Martellus Map.
Why should we study it?
For three principal reasons.
The first is that it very likely
influenced Christopher Columbus'
thinking about the shape of
Asia and the location of Japan.
That's a bold claim.
There are three principal
pieces of evidence for that,
and I'll just mention
one of them which is sort
of the easiest to
convey quickly.
And that is that
Japan is depicted
with its principal access
running north and south,
so it looks like it's at
an angle, but that's just
because of the map's projection.
And Columbus' son in his
biography of his father,
says that his father certainly
would have discovered Japan had
he not believed that it had its
principal access running north
and south.
There is no other document
from this period, that survives
at any rate, that either
says or shows Japan
with that orientation.
So this is quite strong
evidence that this cartography,
if not this specific map,
so it's quite possible
and in fact quite likely
that Martellus made
other similar maps.
So it's not likely that the
Yale map was in Columbus' hand,
but very likely that this
cartography influenced
Columbus' thinking.
It also seems that Martellus'
map influenced Martin Behaim
in creating the earliest
surviving terrestrial globe
from 1492.
We have textual evidence
of earlier globes,
but this is the earliest
one that survives.
And evidence for that
influence can be seen
in Southeast Asia here.
So again, this is
part of the map
where the information
comes from Marco Polo.
Marco Polo does not give
latitudes and longitudes
for the places he mentions.
He says that this city is
15 days east of that city.
So to make a map based on Marco
Polo involves a very large
amount of extrapolation
and guess work,
and it's supremely unlikely
that two people would
do that very similarly.
So when we see the similarity of
Southeast Asia on Behaim's globe
and Martellus' map, it's very
good evidence of influence.
You can see another good piece
of evidence in Eastern Asia
where we have this
triangular peninsula jutting
out into the Eastern Ocean.
Similar shape on both
the map and the globe,
and in both cases, aligned
just north of the tropic.
And third, there are
striking similarities
between Martellus' map
and Martin Waldseemuller's
1507 World Map.
And the similarities I'm about
to run through were noted
when Martellus' map surfaced.
That is to say, scholars
thought, well,
it seems that Martellus'
map must have
influenced Waldseemuller.
The problem was that it wasn't
possible to read the text
on Martellus' map and
explore just how close the
relationship was.
So a few words about
Waldseemuller's World Map.
Again, the only surviving
exemplar is here
on permanent display at
the Library of Congress.
If you haven't seen
it, it's worth a look.
It's printed on 12
sheets, so a printed map,
but it only survives
in one copy.
And, of course, it's famous for,
not just including the New World
but for being the first map
to apply the name America
to the New World, so the
birth certificate of America.
So the two maps are similar, so
they have similar dimensions.
They're both wall
maps for display.
Both cartographers
take advantage
of the wide margins
left by the projection
to include large text
boxes in the lower left
and right-hand corners.
The contours of Africa
are very similar.
This is not really, it's not
good evidence of influence
because in both cases, the
contours of Africa derive
from Ptolemy's Geography.
But when we look at the
contours of Eastern Asia,
which are also very similar,
this is very strong
evidence of influence.
Because again, the information
in this area is based
on Marco Polo.
It's very unlikely that two
people would independently map
Marco Polo's geography
so similarly.
And one final detail is that
Japan on both maps is located
in the same location, the same
orientation, and in both cases,
at the right-hand
edge of the map.
So the big problem with
Martellus map, and the reason
for which it had remained
essentially unstudied
for 60 years, is that
almost all the text
on it had faded to illegibility.
So if we look here
at Northeastern Asia
in natural light, we can see a
few banners indicating the names
of regions, but we really
don't see much in the way
of descriptive text at all,
which is a little surprising
giving the map's large size.
If we zoom in on the
northern coast of Asia,
we can see here there is text,
but trying to decipher it
would be quite difficult.
So this is the most legible text
on the map in Northeastern Asia,
and it's not very legible.
Here's the island of
Japan in natural light.
We would expect there to be
some descriptive text there,
not just because of
the map's large size,
but also because Martellus
himself made this map of Japan,
and on it, he does
include descriptive text.
And so the solution, a way
to try and get at the text
that lurks on Martellus'
map is multispectral
or hyperspectral imaging.
The basic idea of
this technology is
to take a dozen digital photos
of the object, or a small part
of the object, each at
specific frequencies of light.
And those frequencies
range from ultraviolet
through the visible
spectrum into infrared.
Typically, each of those
will reveal something
about the object.
Some of the text,
some of an image.
And the idea is to then
digitally combine those
in a way that, such a way that
everything that's revealed
by each of those
images appears in one.
A very simplified account of
it, but that's the basic idea.
And this technology is useful
for recovering text and images
from documents damaged
by fading, water, fire,
overpainting, palimpsesting
and wrinkling.
So if you imagine a
document that's been burned,
so you might have what
was originally black text
on what is now a
black substrate.
But at certain frequencies
of light,
those two surfaces will
reflect differently, and thus,
it's possible to
recover that text.
And with regard to
palimpsest, one of the earliest
and most important applications
of multispectral imaging
to manuscripts was to the
Archimedes palimpsest.
And so a palimpsest is
where the, a manuscript
in which the text
has scraped off
and the parchment
has been reused.
And using multispectral
imaging, it's possible
to recover the text
that's been scraped off.
And there were good indications
that the Martellus map
was a good candidate
for multispectral imaging.
So returning to Northeastern
Asia,
here it is in natural light.
And I'll now switch to an
image of the same region taken
in ultraviolet light when the
map surfaced in the late 1950s.
And we can see that
there is text everywhere.
This is one of the most exciting
images of a map I had ever seen.
It clearly confirmed that there
was a lot of text on the map.
The question was
how to get at it.
If we look at Southeastern
Africa in natural light
on the left and ultraviolet
light on the right,
we can see that the
ultraviolet image reveals much
of the river system that
stretches down the eastern part
of the continent that's
not readily visible
in the natural light
image on the left.
It also reveals other details.
One looks closely, one
sees cities and the names
of the rivers become a
little bit more evident.
Another example, here's
the southeastern tip
of Africa in natural light.
And now switching to infrared,
we can see that, again,
the rivers, the trees besides
the rivers and some of the names
of the rivers become
more evident.
So, multispectral imaging
involves ultraviolet
and infrared images.
So the fact that ultraviolet
and infrared images
of the map reveal things,
suggests that multispectral
imaging will be successful
in examining the map.
One other example in Africa
in a natural light
image is just possible
to suspect the text is there.
And it's more evident,
if not readily legible,
in an ultraviolet image.
So these are all good
pieces of evidence
that multispectral imaging
will be successful in the map.
So my imaging colleagues
and I applied for a grant
from the National Endowment for
the Humanities to image the map.
Our application was,
fortunately, successful,
and we went to the Beinecke
for ten days in August of 2014
to perform the imaging.
Here we are, that's
me on the left.
It's Ken Boydston, who is the
CEO and founder of MegaVision,
a company that makes excellent
cameras and other equipment
for doing multispectral imaging.
Roger Easton of the
Rochester Institute
of Technology is in the middle.
Roger was responsible for
much of the processing
of the images for this project.
And we have Michael Phelps who
is director of the early Library
of Electronic Texts,
which he runs a project
at Saint Catherine's Monastery
in the Sinai Peninsula,
which is the oldest continuously
operating library in the world
and also has the
largest collection
of palimpsest manuscripts
in the world.
And on the right, we
have Gregory Heyworth,
the founder of our group,
the Lazarus Project.
And it was Gregory's idea
to create a portable system
for multispectral imaging
so that the technology comes
to the institution,
the fragile object,
and we're only interested
in damaged objects,
does not have to travel.
Here is the map out of its case.
It was removed from its case by
the curators of the Beinecke.
You can see it supported
on a large easel
that we brought with us.
The map is tilted
back at 10 degrees
so that gravity holds
it in place.
An easel allowed us to move
the map in front of the camera,
so it allowed us to move
the map both vertically
and horizontally.
When doing multispectral
imaging, it's very important
that the spatial
relationship between the camera
and the lights remain
constant, so the camera
and lights were fixed in place
while we moved the map in front
of the camera to
perform the imaging.
Another view, so looking
from behind the camera,
with the map over to the left.
The metal bars there are
the laser-focusing device.
So the surface of the map
is not perfectly even,
so we had to refocus frequently
as we moved across it.
And starting at the top here,
so up high we have the
multispectral LED light source.
So the way multispectral
imaging used to be done was
that one would shine a bright,
white light at the object.
White light contains
all the frequencies.
And one would then put a filter
in front of the camera lens
so that one would
only obtain the image
at the desired frequency.
So there are two
problems with that system.
The first is that
it bathes the object
in too much energy really.
And then, of course,
any filter induces
at least some distortion.
So now, it's possible
to use LED lights
to shine only the desired,
the exact desired frequency
of light on the object.
So it's a really very small
amount of energy, less, in fact,
than if the object were
lying under these lights.
So we have the LED light
source, and we have a diffuser
which ensures that
the light arrives
on the object evenly
distributed.
Here is the grid of
overlapping tiles
into which we divided the
map for purposes of imaging.
Overlapping, of course,
so we could later stitch
the images together.
One spends a lot
of time in the dark
with these colored
lights flashing.
And one hopes that one's
colleagues have some good
stories to tell us.
The computer cycles through
the different exposures.
But after this long prelude,
let's have a look
at the results.
So we'll begin with
this text block
in the lower right-hand corner.
If we zoom in in a
natural light image,
it's clear that there
are letters,
but trying to read them
is quite challenging.
Here's an infrared image.
Maybe it was helpful with a
few letters, but not very.
The ultraviolet image, which I
don't think is helpful at all.
And the multispectral image.
So, I think this sequence
is very instructive,
because in the past, people
have used infrared light
and ultraviolet light
to try to study text
on damaged manuscripts.
And this shows very clearly how
much more powerful multispectral
imaging is.
Moving into the map proper,
we'll begin with the Alps.
So the map in natural
light really is this murky.
There's the multispectral image.
There are place names
everywhere.
This image caught me a
little bit by surprise.
I wasn't expecting the place
names to be quite that dense.
Northern Asia.
Again, the natural light image.
The multispectral image.
On the left and the right
here, we begin to see some
of the longer descriptive text
that I'll talk about later.
Japan. Again, the natural light
image, multispectral image.
The text appears.
And it looks wonderful until
one tries to start reading it.
And when I did so, I realized
that letters were missing
at the eastern part
of the island.
And so I asked Roger Easton,
is there any other way these
images can be processed so as
to reveal those extra letters?
And Roger, fortunately,
was able to do so.
So here we see those
letters appearing.
Which brings us to the
importance of image processing
or Roger, can you
give it one more try?
So, we spent ten days at the
Beinecke taking the images.
But it's definitely not the
case that one takes the images
and all the text suddenly
and magically appears.
We spent months processing
the images.
That is to say, Roger spent
months processing the images.
And as you'll see
shortly, this is,
this map was particularly
complicated in terms
of the image processing.
But the way we generally
worked was
that Roger would send me images,
I would study the text in them.
I would make a PowerPoint
indicating
where I was still
unable to read the text.
I would send that back to Roger,
and he would try new techniques.
So, if we look at India,
you can just barely see
in the natural light image
near the top of the text,
top of the image there of three
texts, which I circle here,
the multispectral
image certainly helps,
but it's this area
that I want to focus
on where we don't see any text.
Nor do we see any text here
in another processed
multispectral image.
Nor here, in another
processed multispectral image.
And yet here, text
suddenly appears.
So what this means is
that Martellus was
using different pigments
to write different texts in
different parts of the map.
And those different pigments
respond differently to light,
so they appear in some
processes but not in others.
And this certainly
complicated the study,
not just the processing of
the image, but also the study
of the map, because there was
no one image that showed all
of the text on the map.
If we look at another
example in Northeastern Asia,
an area we've looked at before,
so here's the natural light
image, the multispectral image.
It reveals these two
texts quite well.
But here, all we see
are the lines that were
to guide the scribe
in writing the texts.
We don't see the text itself.
So this is another case
where the texts were written
in different pigments that
responded differently to light.
And the fact that some
of the texts were written
in different pigments is
a physical characteristic
of the map that one
would never guess looking
at it in natural light.
So, we were quite successful
in recovering the texts
on the map eventually.
And one thing we can do
with that is undertake this
comparison of Martellus' map
and Martin Waldseemuller's,
explore just how close the
relationship between them is.
Something that had
been impossible
for the 60 preceding years.
So if we begin in Africa,
so here we have a natural
light image of a detail
of Martellus' map that
includes some text.
The multispectral
image makes it legible.
There's a corresponding
text on Waldseemuller's map.
And if we transcribe, what I've
done here is underline the words
that are the same.
So it's the words that are not
underlined that are different.
So, we have, I think
it's four words
of difference, or five maybe.
So we have substantially
the same information
in the same location
on the two maps.
And just to translate, here
there are great wildernesses
in which there are
lions and big leopards
and many other animals different
from ours, that is different
from European animals.
Moving to the Southeast
in Africa.
Again, the natural light image.
Now it's legible.
The corresponding text
on Waldseemuller's map.
And transcribing, we can
see there are two words
of difference, so essentially
the same information
in the same location.
And translating.
The chersidras or
celidras is born here,
a serpent that causes
the ground to smoke.
Moving out into the Indian
Ocean, we have a cartouche,
which is illegible
on Martellus' map.
The multispectral
image makes it legible.
There's a corresponding
cartouche,
a cartouche in the same
location on Waldseemuller's map.
Transcribing, you can
see there's just one word
of difference.
Again, the same information
in the same location.
So very strong evidence
of influence.
Here is seen the orca, a sea
monster that is like the sun
when it shines, whose form
can hardly be described,
except that its skin is
soft and its body huge.
Moving into Asia.
Again, the natural light
image, multispectral.
Waldseemuller, so
here it's interesting
that not only the texts in
the same sort of latitude
and longitude on the two
maps, but in both cases,
they're between these
two mountain ranges.
Transcribing, again,
just one word
of difference between the two.
Here there are monsters similar
to men but with ears so large
that they cover their
whole bodies with them.
So these are the Panotti,
this mythical race of people
that had these huge ears that
they could use as sleeping bags.
Moving to Southeast Asia.
Again, the natural light image,
multispectral, Waldseemuller.
Just one word of difference,
so Martellus says here,
Waldseemuller says there.
Here there are many animals
different from our animals,
different from European animals.
So, there is, in fact,
a very close relationship
between the two maps.
And it seems that Waldseemuller
was doing quite a bit
of copying.
But I think this is where things
start to get more interesting,
because he wasn't
simply copying.
He was choosing what to copy.
So it was a judicious use
of an important source.
So let's now look at some cases
where Waldseemuller departed
from what he found
on Martellus' map.
As we saw before, the
shape of North Africa
on the two maps is very similar.
Again, that's because
in both cases it comes
from Ptolemy's Geography.
But the shape of Southern
Africa is very, very different.
So, as we can see in the upper
right, on Martellus' map,
Southern Africa has
this strange shape
like a human foot
pointing off to the right,
where as on Waldseemuller's
map on the lower left,
it looks much closer
to a modern map.
So this is immediate
and strong evidence
that Waldseemuller was not
simply copying what he found
on Martellus' map.
So let's look at the coast
of Africa, and specifically,
a spot a bit to the north of
where this strong difference
in the contours of the coast.
And thus a spot where
we might expect
that Waldseemuller would
copy from Martellus.
Here is the natural light image.
The place names are not just
illegible, they're invisible.
But they come out quite well
in the multispectral image.
Here is the corresponding
part of the cost
on Waldseemuller's map.
We can immediately see
that Waldseemuller has more
place names than Martellus,
and if we compare closely,
it turns out that not a
single one is the same.
So as keen as he was to
copy the descriptive texts
from Martellus, he did not
copy the African place names,
the coastal Africa place names.
And we can imagine that was
because he had a more recent
source available to him.
So again, Waldseemuller
making judicious use
of one of his sources.
Looking at the Arabian
Peninsula.
Here it is in natural
light on Martellus' map.
This is one of the
few areas of the map
where place names are
legible in natural light.
They are nonetheless
more readily legible
in the multispectral image.
Here is the corresponding
part of Waldseemuller's map.
Given that Waldseemuller
had either this map
or another one very
similar, likely the latter,
in his workshop, and also
given that in neither map,
in both maps all
of the information
in the Arabian Peninsula
comes from Ptolemy.
We might expect
that Waldseemuller would simply
have copied the place names he
found on Martellus' map.
But that is not the case.
He made an entirely independent
selection of place names
from Ptolemy's geography.
And an easy way to show
that is here I've circled
on Martellus' map place
names from the central part
of the peninsula that
are on Martellus' map
but do not appear
on Waldseemuller's.
And here, place names from the
central part of the peninsula
that do appear on
Waldseemuller's map
but not on Martellus'.
So again, a completely
independent selection
of place names from Ptolemy.
Looking at the Northern Ocean.
What we have on Martellus
is an island
with a cartouche
above and below.
It's now legible.
And on Waldseemuller's map,
something very different.
So there is an island,
but it's much smaller.
And there's one long text.
And in fact, the texts
are entirely different.
On Martellus' map the text
comes from Pliny, whereas,
on Waldseemuller's map it
comes from Pomponius Mela.
So a case in which Waldseemuller
did not follow Martellus.
And moving into the Indian Ocean
again, there's a cartouche here
that talks about a
fish called the narco
that makes a fisherman's
arm and whole body numb,
even through the line
and fishing pole.
And for whatever reason,
Waldseemuller does not include
this information on his map.
So it seems we have a case where
Waldseemuller simply chose not
to follow what he found
on Martellus' map.
Looking at the text boxes
in the lower left-hand
corners of the maps.
We can immediately
that Waldseemuller's
text is much longer.
He's talking about the
discovery of the New World,
which evidently hadn't happened
when Martellus made his map.
So even though he's talking
about a different subject,
he nonetheless kept
his eyes on Martellus
for things he could use.
And we can see that
he has copied
that whole final
phrase from Martellus.
So, even when he was taking his
map in a different direction,
he continued to consult
Martellus' map to look
for things that he
could borrow from it.
So I'm going to move now into
one of the most remarkable areas
of Martellus' map, which
is Southern Africa.
Here's the whole of
the continent of Africa
in a multispectral image.
And here are the Mountains
of the Moon, which were,
according to Ptolemy,
the source of the Nile.
We zoom in a little bit.
We can see that although
Ptolemy says that the Mountains
of the Moon were the
source of the Nile,
that Nile River system
continues far to the south
of the Mountains of the Moon.
And moreover, there are many
named cities in this area.
And this is quite surprising
because in most contemporary
maps of Africa, the Mountains
of the Moon were essentially
the southern limit of knowledge.
So here we return to the map
of Africa from the manuscript
of Ptolemy made by Martellus
where we see that the Mountains
of the Moon are at the
southern edge of the map
and thus represent
the southern limit
of knowledge in the interior.
It's also interesting to
compare Martellus' map at Yale
on the left with
his own world map
in the British Library
manuscript of his island book.
So again, on the left,
we have this continuation
of the Nile River System
and many named cities.
On the right, the interior of
Africa is essentially empty.
So we have coastal place
names and a few mountains,
but no river system, no
mountains, no cities,
no really detailed mountain
ranges in the interior.
So, it becomes clear
that Martellus had found
another source of information
about Southern Africa.
And I suggest that
that southern,
that source of information
about Southern Africa
was a map like this one.
This is so-called
Egyptus novelo map.
So it's a map of Africa that
appears in three manuscripts
of Ptolemy's Geography.
Ptolemy's Geography was
updated in various ways.
So, people in the 15th and
16th century recognized
that Ptolemy's geographical
data was about 1,200 years old
and that it was simply
out of date.
And so manuscripts
and printed editions
of the geography were
updated in various ways,
including the addition
of more modern maps.
And this is precisely
one of those maps.
So it's the new map
of Egypt, if you will.
And reorienting it
with north at the top
so that everything is a
little bit more familiar.
We have the Mediterranean,
the Nile Delta, the Red Sea.
At the bottom, part
of the Southern Ocean.
So this map is showing almost
the whole north-south extension
of the continent and many
named cities in the south.
If we zoom in, we can see
just how dense they are.
And the river system, again,
continues quite far
to the south.
And if we put the two
maps side-by-side,
on the Egyptus novelo
map, on the left,
the river system runs
off the right-hand edge.
And we can see at the
corresponding point
of Martellus' map, the
rivers are doing something
very similar.
And in fact, many of
the names of the cities
on Martellus' maps
correspond with names
on the Egyptus novelo map.
So, that's very strong
evidence of influence.
It's thought that
the information
on the Egyptus novelo map
was transmitted to Europe
by quote/unquote Ethiopian
delegates to the Council
of Florence in 1441 to '43.
We have very clear records
that there were Ethiopian
delegates there,
and Ethiopian means basically
Africa south of Egypt.
And we have records that
they were questioned
about the geography of their
homeland, and the questioners,
when they heard the
replies, said, well,
what you say does not agree with
Ptolemy, so you must be wrong.
But it's easy to imagine
that there were other people
a little bit more open-minded
who questioned them
in more detail.
And in fact, we have
a nice confirmation
that the geographical
information on these maps,
on Martellus' map, comes
from Ethiopian sources.
So if we look at the
southeastern tip of Africa,
we can see that there's
a barrier of mountains
and a channel running
across that essentially
separate this peninsula
from the rest of the continent.
And if we compare that with Fra
Mauro's world map of circa 1455,
which is in the [inaudible]
in Venice.
And I've, it's oriented
with south at the top.
I've rotated it to make things
a little bit more familiar.
We see Europe and Africa there.
The part I want to focus
on is Southern Africa.
And if we look at
the southeastern tip
of the continent, we can see
that it has this channel running
across it, separating that tip
from the rest of the continent.
Which is very, very
similar, strikingly similar
to what we see on
Martellus' map.
And in fact, from Fra Mauro says
explicitly, that his depiction
of Southeastern Africa comes
from Ethiopian sources.
People from Ethiopia came to
Venice, and he obtained his,
he rendered Southeastern Africa
according to their descriptions.
So the fact that Fra
Mauro's depiction comes
from Ethiopian sources,
confirms that what we see
on Martellus' map also comes
from Ethiopian sources.
The really exciting
thing about what we have
in Martellus' map is that on the
left in the Egyptus novelo map,
we don't see the eastern
part of the continent.
It's cut off by a meridian.
Whereas, Martellus extends that
geography further to the east.
We see the whole southeastern
part of the continent.
And thus, it seems that
Martellus was working
from a more complete version
of the same information,
and it seems to be the
only more complete version
of that information
that survives.
Which is to say that Martellus'
map has sort of buried
within it a map of
Southern Africa according
to African sources from the
15th century, which in terms
of the cartographic history
of Africa is something
simply remarkable.
So a few conclusions.
One of the exciting things
about this project is precisely
that this map that was this
great un-studiable object
for 60 years is now
studiable in all its aspects.
Eventually, all of the images
generated by this project,
both the raw data and the
process multispectral images,
will be made freely available
on the Beinecke's website.
And so I came to the map with
my questions, but I'm eager
for other people to
come to it with theirs.
Which is precisely
what that will enable.
It will also make it possible as
new multispectral, new processes
for working with multispectral
images is developed,
it will make it possible
for scholars
to reprocess the raw data
and pull more information
from the map without the map
itself having to be disturbed.
I think it's very exciting to
be able to compare the Martellus
and Waldseemuller
maps at long last.
And part of that is that when we
can see how Waldseemuller made
use of one of his most important
sources, it gives us an insight
into how he went
about making the map.
So we don't have diaries.
We don't have workshop
journals from cartographers
of that period, but when
we can see what parts
of the Martellus map
Waldseemuller made use of,
which parts he didn't, it gives
us some insight into his methods
for making a world map.
And finally, the fact that
the Martellus map contains
within it this map of
Southern Africa according
to African sources
is very exciting.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
I'm happy to take questions.
Yes.
>> I think there
was some symposium
at the Library a couple of years
ago, there was another library
that has a copy of the
Waldseemuller map, or is,
could you talk about what
that relationship is.
Because it had the
America on it.
>> Chet Van Duzer:
That's right, so --
>> What is that other one?
>> Chet Van Duzer: It's
the Stevens Brown map
at the John Carter
Brown Library.
And there's great dispute about
when exactly it was printed.
So it came from Waldseemuller's
workshop.
And it's a map very
similar to the world map
in his 1513 edition of Ptolemy.
But the production
process of a 1513 edition
of Ptolemy was very long, and
the argument has been made
that that map was printed
before Waldseemuller printed his
1507 map.
I, the arguments are very
subtle, and to my mind,
they're not strong enough
to overturn the Library
of Congress' claim to have
the earliest printed map
that has the name America.
>> Okay.
>> Hi. Thank you so much for
engaging a fascinating talk.
This was wonderful.
So, I [inaudible]
in Philadelphia.
I was wondering if you would
please explain their 1507 copy
of Waldseemuller [inaudible].
>> Chet Van Duzer: You'll have
to give me a little bit more.
So you mean.
>> Well, I mean they have
a 1507 copy of this book
with the whole foldout
map intact
in the [inaudible]
collection, so.
>> Chet Van Duzer:
Okay, well I will have
to have a look at that.
Is the book in question the
Cosmographiae Introductio?
>> It is.
>> Chet Van Duzer: Okay, I
will have a look at that.
>> And I'm very familiar
with the map,
but I just started working
at the Library of Congress,
and I have not seen the
copy that's on display.
>> Chet Van Duzer: Okay.
>> I don't know if I'm being,
like [inaudible] was saying,
like there is another.
But so.
>> Chet Van Duzer: Okay.
>> But I don't know, I didn't
know if you had seen it or not.
So maybe there's
something wrong with it.
But it was considered
one of its treasures.
They're not very good at
telling people they have it,
so I'm not surprised.
>> Chet Van Duzer: Okay, okay.
Well, I'd be grateful
to learn more about it.
>> Well great, okay.
Fantastic.
Thanks.
>> Thank you for your
stimulating remarks.
And I'm glad that you got
your funding from NEH in 2014.
>> Chet Van Duzer: Yes.
Thank you.
Yes.
>> The shared text,
do they only exist
in those two places
that you know of?
>> Chet Van Duzer: There are
later maps that copy some
of Waldseemuller's texts.
And well I had always
assumed they were copied
from Waldseemuller.
It's possible they were copied
from another version
of Martellus' map.
But there are other, but I think
they're simply copies rather
than, yeah.
Yes.
>> Regarding Southeast Africa.
>> Chat Van Duzer: Yes.
>> The parts that are on
this map but they're not
on Waldseemuller, did he have
the names from these in that,
you know, foot extension on --
>> Chet Van Duzer: Did
Waldseemuller have those names?
>> Yeah.
>> Chet Van Duzer: It does not.
No, there are, in southern, the
coast of Southern Africa, yes,
there are some names
that are the same.
But I'm trying to remember,
Southeastern Africa.
I don't, did the
coastal place names,
I don't think there are
any coastal place names
in that Southeastern tip.
And even going up the
eastern coast of Africa
on the Martellus map, there
are relatively few place names.
But I don't remember whether
there's much crossover there.
>> So he was making a judgment
that this just wasn't accurate.
>> Chet Van Duzer: Well he,
what he was doing
was making a judgment
that he knew he had
something more recent.
>> Okay.
>> Chet Van Duzer: Yes.
>> Do you have any idea what
caused such dramatic fading
or what pigments
they were on the map?
>> Chet Van Duzer: I don't, and
we, it would have been wonderful
to incorporate that
work into our project.
We weren't able to do so.
We were also not able to see
the back of the Martellus map,
which would have been
very illuminating.
But the way it's been mounted,
that just was not possible.
Yeah. Yes.
>> So this is more of
a technical question.
You said that you, I think
the easel was at 10 degrees
and a stationary camera.
You moved the camera
vertically and horizontally.
>> Chet Van Duzer: We moved the
map vertically and horizontally.
>> Okay, so how do you keep a
kind of consistent plane of view
on the map if your
map is angled?
>> Chet Van Duzer: So the
camera was angled as well.
So, the focal plane of
the camera was parallel
to the surface of the map.
>> Is the Lazarus
Project working
on anything interesting
these days?
>> Chet Van Duzer: I hope so.
So the globe that I showed,
the earliest surviving
terrestrial globe is another
great candidate for
multispectral imaging.
It suffered a lot of damage
and some misguided
restorations over the years.
And we have negotiated
access to image it.
So it's, at this point,
it's just a matter
of obtaining the funding.
So that's a very
exciting prospect.
>> Where is that globe?
>> Chet Van Duzer: In the German
National Museum in Nuremberg.
>> How many images
did you take all told?
>> Chet Van Duzer:
That's a good question.
So we actually imaged
the entire map twice
because negotiating the
access is, takes its time.
It's difficult getting the
people and the equipment there.
It costs money.
And you want to be absolutely
sure that everything goes right.
And so we, after imaging
the whole map once,
we made a few adjustments
on the exposures
and imaged the whole map again.
And having done it once, things
went more quickly and smoothly.
But so I'm trying to remember
the exact number of photos,
of images we took for each tile.
So it's 55 tiles.
We did each tile twice.
And in addition to the,
I believe it was 14
multispectral images,
we also took some
images with raking light.
So we're talking about
several hundred images.
And then the number, the total
number of images generated
by the project becomes higher
when you include the
processed images.
So, some parts of the map
were very challenging.
The islands in Southeast Asia,
we still don't have images
that successfully
reveal all the text.
And Roger in his generosity
has tried everything he can
think of.
And so we have many, many
different processed images
of those islands, also of Japan,
and there's certainly
absolutely no reason
to discard any of those.
So, the total archive
is, yeah, many gigabytes.
>> Did the raking
light, by any chance,
reveal anything significant
that the multispectral did not?
>> Chet Van Duzer: It didn't.
In terms of having an image
of the whole map that's nice
to look at, it's great to
have some of the texture,
but it wasn't helpful
in revealing text.
>> When you say you're waiting
for funding of something,
what kind of, what
are you talking about?
>> Chet Van Duzer:
You mean the amount?
>> Yes.
>> Chet Van Duzer: Oh.
So --
>> [Inaudible] Yes, the amount.
>> Chet Van Duzer:
So for this project,
I believe the grant
was for $53,000.
And so the Lazarus Project
provides the equipment for free.
So the essential costs are
transport and lodging really.
For the Beheim globe,
I'm trying to remember.
We do have a budget for it,
but the number is
not coming to mind.
It's a bit more because
the travel is to Germany.
It's a bit more because the
globe is very complicated.
It's not possible to remove
its metal stand entirely.
And the globe does not rotate
freely within that stand.
So, that one will be
much more challenging.
And so we've budgeted
more time for it.
>> What was that globe again?
>> Chet Van Duzer: The name
of the Cartographer
was Martin Beheim.
It was made in 1492.
And again, it's in the German
National Museum in Nuremberg.
>> Could you talk a little bit
about the negotiation process
and how you convince or
persuade the institutions
to let you image
their materials?
>> Chet Van Duzer:
Yes, so really,
the key to that is showing
work that we've already done.
And for something, I guess
the difficult part is the very
beginning of the negotiations
when you first start talking
about the fact that we want
to bring all of this equipment
to your library and sort of
come in and not touch but work
with your most valuable
treasure.
There's naturally resistance.
But then once the
discussion gets to the point
where you can show images,
that tends to change the
tenor of the discussion.
Yes.
>> What sort of framing
was it in before, you know,
you said you were
[inaudible] for imaging.
>> Chet Van Duzer: Not framing.
It's a case.
>> Case, so was it like
a [inaudible] casing
or just a standard case?
>> Chet Van Duzer: It's, I
believe it's all plexiglass.
Does that suffice?
>> Yeah.
>> Chet Van Duzer: Okay.
Yes.
>> Who owns the rights
to the images?
Your group, or is it the
institution that [inaudible]?
>> Chet Van Duzer:
Wonderful question.
And so when we do a project,
we do not own the images.
They all belong to
the institution.
And with some grants,
there's a requirement
that the images be made
publicly available.
But of course, the
institution has to agree
to that before permitting
the project to move forward.
But we do not own the images.
>> Were there any overlapping
sections that gave you clues
that you wouldn't
have gotten otherwise?
>> Chet Van Duzer: What
do you mean exactly?
>> I'm just wondering if,
the way you sectioned it out,
would it have been less fruitful
to have gone through
the process?
>> Chet Van Duzer: With
different partitioning.
>> Yes.
>> Chet Van Duzer: I'm not sure.
I mean any way you
partition something like this,
it will be inconvenient
at some point.
But the matter of the
processing of the images
and the fact I would ask Roger,
is there anything we can do
to bring out something here,
and he would try something,
and another text would
appear over here.
That went on and on and on.
And so, and it was
always surprising.
Yes.
>> What was your personal
happiest surprise you got
[inaudible], like what
was your most [inaudible]?
>> Chet Van Duzer:
Yeah, certainly,
Southern Africa was the
most exciting for me.
And it was, I wasn't expecting
that Southern Africa
would be that rich.
You don't get much of
a clue of that looking
at it in natural light.
And in particular, in Southern
Africa, there's the city
of Prester John, and
that surprised me.
Particularly as on
Waldseemuller's map,
Prester John is in Asia.
So, another interesting
difference between the two maps.
>> Is there a scholarly
consensus today
on the Yale [inaudible] map?
>> Chet Van Duzer: I
think the consensus is
that it's a forgery.
I believe it's on
exhibition at Mystic Seaport.
>> Is it like an ancient
forgery or a new forgery.
>> Chet Van Duzer: Early
20th century, yeah.
>> That's like [inaudible]
chemistry.
>> Chet Van Duzer: Yes, that
was how it was detected, yeah.
Yes.
>> Is there any ideas
of why Waldseemuller put
water on the West Coast?
>> Chet Van Duzer:
There are ideas.
So, it is occasioned
speculation.
So the question is why,
before the European discovery
of the Pacific, why does
Waldseemuller show water
to the west of the New World.
One idea is that this indicates
some sort of pre-discovery
of the Pacific, so an
unknown voyage managed to get
around South America
and see this ocean.
I really think it's
just a deduction
on Waldseemuller's part.
So, Marco Polo says
that Japan is an island.
If Japan is not the same as
the New World, then there has
to be water between them.
I think it's that simple.
>> Now this is just
totally fascinating.
I'm really intrigued
by all the place names.
And you mentioned something
about Ethiopian contribution
to the place names.
Can you talk a little
bit about that?
>> Chet Van Duzer: Yes.
So, in this case, Ethiopia
means very vaguely Africa south
of Egypt.
And so we have, we
have written evidence
that there were quote/unquote
Ethiopian delegates
at the Council of Florence.
And they were in Jerusalem
when they heard about the fact
that Council of Florence
would take place.
And they thought since they
were not that far from it
at that point, they
should attend.
And as I said before, we know
that they were questioned
about the geography
of their homeland.
And that seems to be the source
of the place names
in Southern Africa.
There was actually a
surprising amount of exchange
between Ethiopia and
Europe in the 15th century,
more than we would expect.
So there are, and one bit
of evidence of that is
from [inaudible] saying
that he had Ethiopian,
he questioned Ethiopian
people in Venice.
But there's much more.
So there are other possible
ways the information could have
gotten to Europe,
but the Council
of Florence seems most likely.
>> Is there any question about
the authenticity or the age
of the manuscript annotations?
Like could they have been
added at different points,
or are you assuming that it
was all in one production?
>> Chet Van Duzer: I did not see
any evidence of later editions.
The handwriting is consistent.
I'm trying to think of
anything that looked.
>> The fading is consistent.
>> Chet Van Duzer: The fading
is certainly consistent, yes.
So I didn't see any
evidence of that.
>> Stephanie Stillo: All
right, thank you so much.
[ Applause ]